et
[Musique]
haricots ça glisse jean ne pas manger
souvent
quelque chose a changé dans la façon de
nourrir des big three
où sont donc passés les purs et où on
est c'est vraiment le plus comme nous
vient des jeunes parents adoptent la dm
e la diversification menée par l'enfant
c'est une méthode qui introduit les
aliments solides dès que bébé atteint
l'âge de 6 mois on profite ainsi du
stade de développement où il veut tout
porter à sa bouche on ne le ok du
médecin aussi donc on s'est lancés et
dès la première journée
capoté sur la nourriture vraiment là
j'ai un peu seulement pour toi ici pour
les bébés ça doit être vraiment
meilleurs de manger ce moment au citron
qu'elle mangeait une cure itx outtara
peut faire on estime que c'est plus
familial d'avoir ces repas tous ensemble
c'est lui qui va décider un peu de ce
qui veut manger combien vont en manger
même s'ils l'ont fait avec leurs aînés
de 4,1 il continue de s'informer sur
cette approche développée par une
infirmière au royaume-uni cas des livres
qui existent aussi sur le sujet parce
que effectivement on peut pas donner les
aliments de n'importe quelle façon pour
prévenir les risques d'étouffement
j'suis indirecte de m'accuser on va
devoir rapidement les sur la v ème heure
les croquettes de riz et de légumes
c'est devenu une tendance étonnant la
nutritionniste sandra griffin le voit
bien dans les commentaires qu'elle
reçoit lors de ces séances en ligne
marienval ne vu quelqu'un son entourage
voilà tu as brocoli icap à cause de la
grosseur du morceau c'est parce que abb
six mois ça ouvre et sa ferme la main
donc il faut donner des morceaux qui
sont assez groupe entre neuf et dix mois
il va faire la pince entre le pouce et
l'index donc là oui on pourrait donner
des plus petits morceaux il faut choisir
des aliments nutritifs riches en fer
mais aussi des textures adapté aux
capacités du poupon on veut chaque
bouchée qu'ils mangent là ça lui apporte
le des nutriments et des saveurs des
textures donc on est vraiment dans dans
le développement du coup le
développement de ses capacités de manger
et de son intérêt envers les aliments
l'âge recommandé pour introduire les
aliments est passé de 4 à 6 mois dans le
but de prolonger l'allaitement maternel
l'idée c'est que la dmr favorise la
poursuite de l'écho des signaux de faim
et gracieusement par l'enfant donc c'est
lui qui va gérer les quantités qu'ils
consomment versus l'approchons nouri al-
hackers
professeur en nutrition véronique
gingras a fait la dm e avec sa fille
rose mais la science n'est pas claire
sur les bénéfices que bien des parents
attribuent déjà à cette façon de faire
les rares études par exemple ne mesure
pas de bénéfices dans le développement
de la dextérité film vient juste de
grosses études à ce jour sur la dmr à ma
connaissance puisque on a démontré qu'il
n'y avait pas d'effet négatif et donc
pas plus de risques d'étouffement il n'y
a pas de risques de carences
alimentaires non plus chez l'enfant ça
affecte pas la croissance depuis quatre
ans les ergothérapeutes de l'hôpital
sainte-justine répondent ou nombreuses
questions de parents on ne revient sur
la motrice t on à un gain sur
l'exploration sensoriel est mais en même
temps et si les repas dur 60 90 minutes
deux à trois fois par jour l'enfant en
même temps moins d'opportunités à
manipuler des jouets quels enfants sont
en contact avec les aliments ou avec des
jouets à l'extérieur du repos le
développement va se faire de la même
façon il n'ya pas de méthode qui est
meilleur que l'autre ça je pense que
c'est un message important pour tout le
monde c'est un choix parental qui
convient à un et qui peut ne pas
convenir à l'autre le bavoir intégral
c'est un peu un must parce que oui la
méthode co certains débordements la
pomme
bbc soit sa forme de gaspillage
alimentaire ça rentre au poste en
morceaux comme en purée le repas de bébé
se termine avec l'incontournable qui
brouillait et quelques protestations
puis il